today we're honoring one of the greatest
brewers
of all time number eight
ryan brawn
to the milwaukee brewers and the people
of wisconsin
where do i even start
it's become very rare for professional
athletes to have the opportunity to play
in one uniform for their entire career
i'm incredibly grateful that i was one
of the few
and even more grateful that it was with
the milwaukee brewers
14 years one jersey
and one city
thank you milwaukee
go brewers
the result of the punch their ticket to
the division championship
for the victory here this afternoon and
freddie peralta
hoping for some more milestones too he's
10 strikeouts away from joining corbin
burns
and brandon woodruff in the 200
strikeout club
bouncer into the right side escobar no
problem for him
one away
so here's lindor who's over eight in
this series and struck out four times
last night
and the door cracks one a deep right
center forget that that is way out of
here back up in the second deck
lindor with a tape measure shot for his
18th of the year his first hit in the
series is a home run and the mets have
an early one-nothing lead
to the left side ureas nice play
able to make a good throw to get
conforto
very used to that you go down you stop
yourself and get yourself in position to
make a throw good play i mean he goes
down to stop his momentum so he's able
to make a good throw to first
well done by louisa
and carlos carrasco on the mount hoping
to get off to a better beginning yeah
that's for sure as last time out
he suffered a loss
again gave up the run in the first
innings but it was a six innings of only
two runs against the fight and phil's
a pitch well again as he settled down
after the first inning all four lead off
man is aboard here comes willie adamus
hit the ball pretty well since
he came off the injured list
high drive deep left brewers lead in the
first two to one
mile mile was that ball crushed
his 24th of the year
mcneal took a couple of steps back and
then enjoyed the ride on that one
brewers two
new york one here in the opening inning
neato to center
lorenzo cain drifting back still back
warning track leaps
lorenzo kane
robs a home run from tomas nedo
and christian yelich coming up with the
bases loaded
to first alonzo fields he'll take it to
the bag brewers get a run out of it
long to third william domes winds up at
second and the batter is eduardo escobar
to right face head
wong's in adamus being waved around he's
gonna score
the brewers have opened it up as the
ball gets away throw to second safe yeah
how about that hustle wow
boy how about escobar last couple of
days does he come up with some big hits
or what base hit to right and an error
and it's 5-1 milwaukee
this one's lined into center field and
conforto's got a lead-off hit
alonzo drives one to right field back
toward the corner and that's a fair ball
going off the wall conforto racing for
third he'll be held up there alonzo
dives into second base with a double
so pete going the other way with power
drives one off the fence and right for
his 25th double of the year and the
pitch
it's laced into left field that is down
for a base hit yelich feels conforto
into score alonzo right behind him onto
second with a double
is javi baez a two-run double and the
mets that much closer now five to three
milwaukee baez motioning to the crowd
let's hear it now
so two out and now kevin pillar is going
to bat for jeff mcneal so he bats here
with two out and two on with the tying
runs on base
and pilar loops one into shallow left
center that may fall and it does for a
base hand alonso races in to score baez
will stop at third a bloop single by
kevin pillar as a pinch hitter drives in
a run to get the mets within one it's
now five to four
long center field nemo back looking
off the top of the fence
lower
a double for colten wong and he missed a
home run by about five inches
right over the top of the wall in center
field
to the third baseman vr lauer coming
home
wong stops at third at thomas into
seconds and the mets just gift wrapped a
run to the brewers and no kidding and
maybe more i'll tell you vr gets rid of
that baseball right away i mean it's an
easy out at home
ground ball left side lindor played him
right there throw to first alonzo
couldn't pick it two are gonna score
eight for milwaukee how about those gift
runs right there
oh my
that first vr now lindor those are huge
it's 8-4
that's a two-on for alonso
ashby's 2-2 pitch swing and a miss
alonso chased a changeup down in the
dirt and ashby gets a huge strikeout
to finish off
the top of the seventh inning magic
number is one you get three outs
and the brewers
are the champs in the division josh
hayder on to try and close it out
and pop some champagne
one two pitch
8-4 brewers
the stretch
the pitch
swinging fly to left this should do it
yell it is there it's over
they have won it
josh hader comes on
in the ninth
to set the mets down one two three
and the brewers are going
to the postseason again
they're the central division champions
celebrating on the field
celebrating in the stands
congratulations to the crew again
as they have taken care of business
all by themselves